how's it going there citizens of the reject Nation
it's John and Andrew Gordon back in the saddle
once again to check out a film I am very excited
for it is time for I believe 2016's Shin Godzilla
Greg and I have been checking out the Monarch
series Godzilla minus one is dropping now might
even already be out so we got Godzilla on the
brain Andrew are you excited I am so excited I
want to see the film that went up against Batman
B Superman in 2016 absolutely that that was that
weekend boy duking it out for Supremacy I just me
the year I don't know the weekend I'm rewriting
history right here exactly leave a like guys
for kaiju for the tradition of monster movies in
general and don't forget to subscribe the channel
hit that notification Bell so you can be kept up
with all the new releases we got dropping each day
here at the real rejects as always thank you to
prepper for helping us edit down these highlights
it's a tough task and hey if you want to see the
complete Shin Godzilla experience alongside Andrew
and myself get every little moment that doesn't
make these reaction highlights why don't you come
on over to patreon.com theal reject where you
can sync up with your own copy of shin Godzilla
got tons of goodies over there we got shows and
movies with reaction highlights and watch alongs
included exclusively it's blast you'll be super
sexy if you and uh hey I'm ready to go Andrew
you got anything else to say let's do it let's do
[Music] it right to business love it classic I'm
excited not a pleasure craft for
long they left a
crane that's what they want you to think
damn nice oh no it's going to say
when's this going to become found
footage whoa damn oh my God I like
how we're seeing it from people's
povs
right to business jeez the
cinematography it's liking it so
far it's got to be so horrifying you're
just driving under the tunnel man
yeah
oo it's a bloody
volcano damn God everything is is already so
organized I like that this movie is
wasting no time just getting right to
business cool a slide got to have
fun in your Kaiju apocalypse you
know oh no that is so terrifying that
sound that's awesome too yeah oh it's
good teases though this kind of feels like
like a District 9 Godzilla movie it's good
comparison
already wasted so much time talking about this
theme is that where we're getting Godzilla
versus me it'll happen when they get desperate
enough makes sense but it's uh fascinating
how they're really leaning on the police iCal
side here oh sure well and just yeah the
disaster management all around yeah no I
mean
uhoh
uhoh yeah stay in line guy we got bureaucracy to
uphold
damn makes sense usually it's the
opposite way economic first people
second what about that red ring
that is quite a sight [Music]
though
you're not going to think it's a joke
soon I love these teases look
outside
damn giant Marine creature
I would jump up and say you
see and bring me my brown pants I was going to say
my pants would definitely be brown
right now I was just about to say
[Music]
that this is an expensive giant SE
creature let just heard it that way make
some signs say go this way yes create a
shoot
oh yeah and it's not deep enough for a
sub
you got to cover all the PES
guys all of
yes oh God fascina whoa it's getting
closer these guys got it the Dream Team
this one guy's on loan from the Star Wars
Universe I know this
guy this guy's super
familiar hold on to those Scruples
boy oh my God jeez man
what God I love the disconnect
between what's happening literally
right outside and what's going on in
this office what a waste of time that
was oh god well this is definitely a deep
fake it's a fair
assumption this is fascinating
I'm curious what they're going to
say oh my
God jeez I feel like there there is
a definite humorous streak despite
how like devastating this destruction
is of course of course this poor guy
oh oh oh no oh no and and I get the sentiment
want to keep the public calm yeah but
like so um we live in like a post
cameraphone world this is not going
to last you know what I just said uh forget
that sorry about new Intel is whoa that is
[Music] disturbing just assume the experts
don't know a thing this is unprecedented on
the one hand it's the criticism of
like the experts don't even really
know but then also like what do you do
oh my God I wonder how long it's going
to take for all this to break down like
we're in so many controlled organized
rooms
oh goodness it's going to have like all
of Japan destroyed by the time you guys
come up with an actual plan now the problem
arises too like can you fire into civilian
territory [Music] that was
poetry right there D and
Britt it's what I'm
saying oh
boy what else you gonna
do oh God
oh my God I don't know what you do in
that situation got to start running
there's some beautiful shots in this movie oh
god wow that is some Mayhem and
destruction God just the eyes on this
thing yeah like it it it does look like
a real Komodo or something like that
oh no oh no there's families and people
inside oh oh
[Music] no get the bug spray out big ass
pest we got here whoa I mean yeah what
point at this point you have no choice I
love it they're just super imposing the
handbook if he's not got cause for pause
already yeah it's a very difficult
decision I really wouldn't
even know what to decide in
that second just because of how unprecedented it
is H beware of unfounded [Music]
optimism I was going to say in a
situation like this you just got
to trust your own gut and do what you
think is best for you and your family
yeah is this creature like related
to gods or is it be going to be like
become the Godzilla we know whoa
is he taking a nap is this just
dead there's arms growing out is
it going to like evolve or malt or
something oh I'm learning to walk
again oh my God it is sprouting
some arms whoa interesting oh
is he getting bigger yeah oh
oh fascinatingly odd Choice with the
eyes look at God the inside of its mouth
like it's like it feels like
it's just playing on a speaker in
City Jesus
Christ great attention to details too
the amount of property damage in time
of clean up for this yeah Godzilla
insurance going to be through the
roof you bet it does like how formation there
that was pretty cool shot yeah and
it's so Eerie with him just standing
there evu this just going to
make it stronger and angry career
yeah for the head if you kill the brain
then you kill the ghoul and its motor
functions oh damn
it oh my God
respect that's a fierce trolley problem
oh oh Atomic breath just
love how many telephones that
involved oh jeez right at the camera oh my God
this is great they're great at realizing the
scale and it like even though the effects aren't
the most photo real like it really sells them to
the point where it doesn't matter it looks
it looks great even though you can tell it's
animated oh I get it life
has to continue and Go on
but everything's his business is normal the
rest of the country I'm glad the world's
chipping in [Music] good oh wow I mean it's
only 100 I'm sure it's going to be way more
but still I figur it'd be a little more than that
it's good though it kind of grounds it makes it
more tangible you're like 100 people damn like
thousands and thousands it becomes like less less
tangible
fair you smug [__] he's just got unfound
optimism that's right he's going to get us all
killed that is quite a a
scene that would not be fun to be part
of that cleaning crew like where do we
start we working on this for the rest of my
life yeah o it's like a shot out of an old
war movie on the flip side I'd rather
be on the cleaning crew than on those
boats
I'm curious how they lost him in the first
place yeah his scale just dive back into the
water uh oh fifth
floor I always want to see how
Godzilla would affect the economy in
census bureaucrats least they admit it really
big I love these odd like camera
choices yeah spatial povs and stuff like
that going prepared this time
wolf nerd troublemakers academic
Heretics such a great intro this guy's got
bars oh yeah well his arms were only
like this big so definitely got more
evolving I want to see them
try to communicate with it
nuclear power
plant did they not see him doing that Atomic
breath thing they did not I assure you or
they're still discussing it now yeah
yeah guess that was just for us the
audience
oh just some unexplained
radiation it's me when I beat the end of a tough
game new clear
Vision yeah and he'll be here any minute to
sort your [__] out that's what we Americans
do what John Goodman in Kong
Skull Island we got to find
Randa just us Japan so win win absolutely
win-win fraking
yichi
good we want to know everything he knows red
notice isn't that the movie with The Rock
and then r Reynolds I think so out yeah
her was their best film it's a reference
clearly yes that
too no
need whoa he said that name
he said it he said it is cod
name he gave it an English name that's the name
Goa
oh no oh boy that is quite a lot of radioactive
material that was like piles of radioactive
materials surprised only one game
or at least so far I'm sure there's
more yes
yes God personal service I love her bilinguals
yeah going to say she's my
favorite character by far so
far we all do after a lengthy series of phone
calls gamma rays oh that's why it grows
big like the Hulk that's right and it's
shorts ripoff no no just my my
my fun little reference of the
film you have to fire on it to find
out needs more radiation [Music]
oh oh [Music] name save goira I mean
those people will be out there too
you know they'll be like this is Nature's
plan which maybe I'm all for not destroying
creatures and all that but when it's
destroying everything that's different
situation
good it's got more business in
Town love this oh he looks he looks different
now yeah definitely looks more classic Godzilla
yeah ah the scale just looks
like he's made of molten
[Music]
magma oh what a shot
[Laughter] I'm curious if they're going
to have any Godzilla POV shots in the
film although they're doing a
great job at the ground level
scale for for sure oh that trail
that is [Music] insane oh you're
crazy this is even my final
form is that going to do anything going
in t citizens leave citizens go inside
just go wherever Godzilla isn't at the
moment yeah again what what tail oh okay
that tail right past the yeah SCS and
[__] flying around oh man yeah these
ground shots are are incredible though oh my
God Jesus man this are really impressively
assembled no
pressure unrestricted weapon
use we're all counting on
you a little feel a little bit like
2014 just a little bit little bit but
we are seeing Godzilla a little more than the 2014
version I really oh I feel bad he's in a tough
position oh boy and little bullets ain't going
to do nothing you need to you need to send
like I don't know projectile missiles or
something hey it's worth a shot no pun
intended
[Music]
sound the way they prolonged this
too oh boy yeah
I love that they broached the idea like
a little while ago and then we think
we don't need to use it and now we're
going straight to like as much force as
possible nope nope these are just these
are just love Taps to him yeah oh my god
wow right in the face wow beautiful
oh my God that did nothing that did
nothing they're going to have to science
the [__] out of this yes nothing else
it seems is going I don't know if tanks are
going to work if missiles don't drop a tank
into his mouth with the barrel pointing
down cuos that oh they're going to shoot
him in the shin that's why it's called
Shin Godzilla makes sense now someone
you could translate the the the the title
for me in the comments Oh I thought you had
it right there definitely cuz hitting
them in The Shins is going to be the
key nice so damn W oh
myness that is so much Firepower doing nothing
I mean it looks like he's
getting a massage probably
honestly oh my god oh
no he is so damn
strong ah
this guy's having having fun
over here this guy's enjoying
himself oh great
success no Godzilla's like my turn yeah you
done
a wow wow o oh this poor
guy thank you for all the love Taps felt good
yeah that camera panning up
too that's awesome I don't
love he's just strolling getting
this cardio yeah just taking a
walk I don't know about you but I view that as a
success sure I we I'll take
it from a certain point of
view we don't want to look weak yeah
that's the important thing let the
Americans take the rap for looking
weak when their efforts are futile
see the night and the blackout that is
and what a clever like effect solution
[Music] [Laughter] [Music] too hey you wanted
our help this is what we're doing yeah we come
to blow [__] up that's what we do and we
expect way to do it blow it up real [Music]
good
yes
props I do like how they're presenting him as
a very honorable human being
seems like a real human with
[Music] compassion I sure hope so
man you really think doing the car was the good
idea oh [__] God in the way
the sound all dropped out whoa
whoa if it please we can kill
it that's right that's what we do us
USA I feel like that's just going to
get csilla angrier n dude this is American [Music]
propaganda thank you godzill for backing me up not
making the roar oh yeah oh Atomic oh we
like you that oh this [Music] music the
jaw
oh wa secondary eyelid oh damn
[__] this is giving me Vibes of the hydrogen
bomb in Terminator 2 a Sky beam everyone's
favorite the sky beam but when it comes from
Godzilla I don't mind this a fascinating way
they animate like the mouth and the and the
changing of the beam and all that the target
is shooting some unidentified weapon from the
front bomber 2 and bomber three will Circle
in from behind yeah it's not a good idea Roger
payback I love I love the American like actors
and voice overs they get for little stiff
oh my oh my god oh no oh no oh my god oh
[__] this is
nuts holy crap
Homeland oh
wow like why are you guys bothering me I'm just
taking a walk yes welcome to hell ah
hell on Earth I wonder what the count
is up to now the body count you know
three 400 people per second per square
block oh
dormant it's going to say I can't
imagine the radiation levels but don't
worry they'll have a very effective system
for getting the iodine tablets out [Music]
there the Prime Minister [Music]
yeah this music is so
daunting that's it among other things
[Music] [Laughter] nothing like water to calm the
nerves it is you is there W vatka
in that water not get Hasty right
now okay agriculture
Minister oh Jesus no
that's what I was thinking the whole time this is
not a position you would want in in a time like
this never said
never but but seriously though like
we're we're in a joking type of
mood oh hell of a
speech
Montage just take a giant chainsaw and cut the
from the neck up yeah or like a giant swimming
pool filled with water put his foot in it
you know maybe he'll get embarrassed and
leave the is a movement centered in China and
Russia to take gazer from under the control of
the Japanese government and put it under the
control of international organization as for
this government we strongly hope that
Japan and the US can perfectly control
godilla together control wof oh no man as
the Army Express as the backbone of the
government we have to respect the offer the
at the center of decision making of that we
will I like it it appears that Godzilla
has something like a built-in phased array
radar he's dropping skin I would assume
he's evolving more he's like molting again
again uh yeah about that part nope
nope if there's even a 1% chance
Godzilla could end up on the coast
we need take as absolute certainty the
film I referenced earlier yes the best
film at some point we need
to come to a realization
weapons are not good on especially new [Music]
clear great
out yeah it is a great cran out interesting shot
yeah I like how it's staying too on
on a tracking cran out yeah without
cutting I need emergency Powers
then I will become the emperor
is oh boy oh
[Music] nope I don't blame
you that's what you think debatable
you have the science-based evidence
to oh yes they're going to freezing like Megatron
was frozen at the beginning of
Transformers that's what we need
dude you're going to lose the world if you don't
yeah I mean I don't think
it don't matter that much
anymore see sciencing the [__] out of it I mean
it seems like the only thing that could possibly
work I like this music
choice
damn uhoh the reboot has
started
oh we think our time for the nuclear strike
against Godzilla has been being
decided countdown will begin in 5
minutes H it's not that
hard oh my goodness yeah I was going to
say what evacuation plan can you come
up with that isn't just going to lead to endless
gridlock why not just bring it
now you scratch my back I scratch
yours he created Godzilla
[Music]
there's something to that or
perhaps it's meant to be like
placed on top of a different
paper and they'll both line
up what you got me ah of
course
wow
whoa
wow sure as many raw materials
do
no whoa nice that's that's a cool
POV whoa I knew computers had a mind of Their
Own
some kind of
test
yeah and it's a kinky
plan
I got
time it's okay
man yeah we don't have that much time our
friends are progressing with an effective
deep freeze plan I think this country is betting
on it and you're raising that bed also I see know
she wants to tell to f off so bad me I'm
okay but you with your fastidious career
and the Patterson name mud will stick
yeah think about your career right now
becoming president in your 40s will disappear
this is about you hey Koko good luck yeah
[Music] yeah every time this music CU starts
I think it's going to turn into the aam theme
song getting [__] done music came
yeah I was going to say do you need a country
to be a PM people keep saying that like you
think about your career down the line like
dude we're not going to have a place to
be before the Americans come in and blow it all up
just seeing it off in the background
from that distance yeah it's so
imposing ready
break oh my
God who wow wa wake up that's why they call
it Shin Godzilla just drive
those trins right into his
shins oo how how far is the
[Music] reach yeah watch your
[Music] baby we must continue I mean variables are
inevitable jeez man again like like how
far like are people seeing these beams
over Europe and America and everywhere
else like at least the the nearby Asian
countries must be seeing this oh no from
it tail get the whip oh my god oh damn
oh mouth and tail same time both
ends God damn there you go I like
that the the purple flame is like the
hottest fun who Damn
no oh my God o dominoes I going to
say is that a domino effect we're
having
yeah that's insane oh wow oh I feel
bad for [Music] him let's go crane
team oh putting the coagulation
in him yeah just drop those pills
in there drop time to take your
medicine Godzilla drop drum after
drum oh
[Music] wow this is like a a city scale
surgery oh God oh God and now we got to watch
the loading bar ah [__] [__] [__] I
feel like there's again going to be a a
delay it it worked but it's going to be a
delay ah God what a fascinating
strategy Just Launch public transit at
it who this is an effective
bomb I got to say oh oh my
God this is the baddest ass sequence I've ever
seen involving cranes which
you know I can think of a
couple they must had some extra
no it's interesting I kind of
feel bad for Godzilla but obviously I do want
them a look like he's drinking it
[Music] now please work
yeah oh it cannot be destroyed
oh no Godzilla freeze got to take a picture of
you negative oh
it's a fascinating
movie that's what I want to see
a sequel where we just watch the
cleanup happen yeah and a new system of politics
[Music] instilled you picking
up what I'm putting down
yes it
will I mean the world deserves to
know oh that'd be cool of
course I mean let's be real
right and I will own nothing oh good
man we got beef oh oh whoa
what what what is what I don't even know what that
was growing out of it I have so many questions
yeah I'm like what kind of what kind of mutations
are those mutations that were taking place still
evolving you know from all the nuclear input or
is that like like beings that were like grafted
on just from all the different explosions and
and and uh destruction it was from that cranial
surgery and stuff just started growing in funny
places you know when you get surgeries uh not at
the right times things start happening sure sure
but you know before we go any further the thing
I'm I'm not uncertain about is the best place
to support the trannel and get the trannel the
channel and get yourself uh a nice fresh drip
in the process Andrew's got the Classic tickets
over reject Nation shop.com probably be good if I
named the website rnation shop.com if you want to
grab yourself some swag we got the who influences
the influencers te we got uh space babies of the
Galaxy we got the new boys inspired America's
ass t-shirt tons of good stuff over there so uh
if you want to support the channel and rock you
know like display your pride in the nation reject
uh head on over there we very much appreciate it
but anyway I I I cut you off no no no you're good
you're good uh no I really enjoyed the film uh I
love the look of Godzilla in this and the way he
evolved it was really unique uh I'll go more into
that in a little bit also I enjoyed the political
satire just all the how we were just so focused
on all the uh the politics of everything just
like and again it was a very unprecedented event
so it's like I did not envy the Prime Minister
just anybody in that situation I'm like I would
literally not know what to do obviously maybe
the logical thing to do is just to attack but then
again you got to view collateral damage and other
things like what do we do in a situation like
this this is so unparalleled and unprecedented
so um I just thought the you know the storyline
like were the characters like you know great or
anything I mean I'd say there was one or two
characters I really actually enjoyed following
for the most part uh you know the guy who came up
with the uh the coagulation with the team and all
and then that other pret woman who wanted to have
the ambition of becoming president I really liked
her character a lot um but just from the political
standpoint I actually really enjoyed it just you
know giving us that Insight of what would happen
if a monster of this mon of this scale uh you know
decided to attack a major Metropolitan uh City
and all so um from that point of view I really
enjoyed the film and just again the a lot of the
cinematography I really appreciated there was just
I mean just a lot of the POV shots and also there
was that one specific shot where they were just
having that conversation and we were doing out
on that tracking shot just and also too inside
the computer and I could go on and on about the
cinematography but what did you uh think of the
film no I loved it I I loved the way that this
was constructed and the way that yeah it brought
all of its elements together to create something
that's definitely within the tradition of of you
know the Godzilla Legacy that exists now but also
that feels very kind of invigorated and fresh and
uh and yeah there's something real funny to me
about watching this because obviously there are
elements of the ecological commentary and the
you know commentary on nuclear proliferation
that Godzilla movies often touch upon but I feel
like there's also a metal layer of like the legacy
of Godzilla as a figure kind of I I don't know
if that's just me but I kept catching elements
folded into this where I'm like we got Japan and
we got America and they're all kind of dealing
with this creature and like there's that point
where they're like oh we're getting this Intel
from the Americans and I know that there are
you know backs and forth uh forths in terms of
the rights and like how uh in the American movies
they can use Godzilla versus in the Japan uh the
Japanese movies and stuff like that and uh and
like what's accepted as part of the lore and the
approach here versus there and uh the fact that
you do get this like heavy American presence uh
partway through and continuing through the
movie I thought was kind of a neat uh sort
of funny little thread especially with like the
different formations Godzilla goes through and
uh yeah just the debates about the nature and
obviously we live in a different point in time
where you know the the original film you know is
is largely in reaction to atrocities during World
War II and Pearl Harbor and all that stuff and and
you know nuclear uh just the nuclear situation in
the world has changed but that's still very
much sort of the Catalyst for it all and so
uh it's interesting then that you would have this
scenario and it didn't go on the nose in terms of
the past history but yeah this scenario of like
the Americans are coming in they're like we got
to Nuke this thing now yeah the American thing to
do yeah and then you know them racing to get this
alternative solution together that by the end of
the movie you're sitting there going like this
isn't like the solution and it's interesting that
they would arrive you know this is a temporary
solution and it's interesting that they would
arrive at the idea that like yeah we're going
to have to learn to coexist because as of now
the only way we have found to mitigate any of
this creature's progress is just to to freeze it
you know to stop it exactly I was waiting for him
to say welcome to Godzilla World um but uh yeah
no I mean from at least my recollection of what
I've seen in the American films of that I watched
in Godzilla like most of the time when they've at
least uh I know the film we we don't want to
talk about the 1998 film they used uh actual
weapons and that was his weakness uh in in that
film my only yeah exactly but I I do like in this
film and this approach where like that literally
does nothing it's like love Taps to him um and I
love the idea of actually using our brains
and sciencing the [__] out of it not say
that again but um I I do love that whole idea of
you know finding a different type of approach and
way because that's that becomes formula at some
point I'm like all right using weapons again to
stop but also that and oh sorry sorry I was just
going to say also too I like that that's a source
of strength for him too when you're giving when
you're shooting nuclear weapons at him he could
just use it right back at you I just thought that
was really interesting and unique as well too
another one of those things though that that and
I'm trying to remember where this would be I mean
we're only I guess right after Godzilla 14 this
is right after 14 so I'm wondering where we are in
the American lore with them because they because
the American movies have brought in that idea of
like oh he feeds directly on nuclear energy and it
certainly yeah like sort of comes in here and then
by the end they're sort of like again that metal
layer came back up to me where I was like they're
kind of acknowledging that like all we can do in
any of these movies is temporarily stop Godzilla
because Godzilla will always come back and in
that way we are coexisting but but yeah I like
the way that this combined those random flavors
that I've been harping on with yeah like this very
uh realistic semi docu style like there are a lot
of elements that reminded me of like a District 9
approach where you're going to just so much uh
you're you're doing semi documentary but you're
also just pulling in like footage that looks like
it could have been sourced for some kind of news
report but then you're going narrative and and as
as far as characters go like I don't begrudge this
I think this movie brought an a nice approach
to that because you know it's well documented
that the second you start talking about human
characters in any Godzilla movie everyone you
know kicks in the door and it's like nobody cares
exactly and so like I don't mind in the least that
we didn't like have some kind of central you
know protagonist I mean we kind of do there
are a couple people we focus most on but I liked
that this represent presented a collective effort
and I'm sure um in some ways this reminded me of
watching uh what was that show called all of us
are dead in that so much and I'm sure other things
have done this too but that's you know sort of the
touchdown that r that Rose to mind for me where
you're watching the the downsides of the system
as it exists uh in Japan here for this example uh
you know the their democratic system and the ways
in which it's you feel for the struggle because
you're like I get why we need all this bureaucracy
and clearance in theory I get why we need to have
experts and everybody kind of coming together and
sort of breaking down the situation and figuring
out what to do but at times you don't have the
time for that so you do sit there going like man
they they've wasted a lot of time by going like
okay let's get a plan together based on what
we know and at a certain point you're kind of
sitting there going like I don't know like nobody
seems to know because every time you go with your
best plan it's just not applicable you know and
so them coming in towards the end they're like you
know this is the one thing that we know like you
know we got to Nuke them cuz nothing can withstand
the heat of a thermonuclear weapon and that's one
of those things where yeah it's like the hubris
of thinking that you know and so like yeah you
can't necessarily just come out and be like hey
this is what's going on but in some ways I think
the argument exists that there's got to be a more
efficient way or there's got to be a more direct
way and that you know sculpting and wrangling and
trying to control the image and the information
is this perilous process because on the one hand
yeah I understand why you wouldn't want to just
go on TV and be like holy [__] there's a Kaiju
outside but at the same time I think the the great
you know a great thing about the First Act or so
of this is that you are just knees deep in this
contrast of like every time they cut outside it's
utter chaos and every time they cut inside it's a
bunch of people very remove like focused on this
but very removed from the reality of this and I
love the way that it early on they're strategizing
and you're just watching as these strategies are
being completely outmoded like in real time right
there's only so much you could do I mean the Prime
Minister was saying that there's no way you can
come on land and then a half a second later he's
coming on the L I mean again it's so unprecedent
it's like that's why I was like I have no en for
what is going on in such crazy chaotic time I mean
this is not something that you can prepare for
well it's unprecedented yeah and I think the the
argument then becomes like at a certain point it
might be better to just come out and be like this
is unprecedented and we have our best people
on like again statecraft I don't know how you
would qu the panic but yeah being able to come out
and not waste time and Reon I get you have to try
stuff but at the same time being like no we're
confident it's not going to come up on land for
for reasons that we've contrived because nothing
like this has ever happened before for sure and
in regards to your comments earlier about you know
in films like in these Godzilla films like yeah we
don't want to focus too much on the characters
we I'm fine when they no no no no I was I was
totally fine with it like and again it was really
more about those I mean again it was a collective
Ensemble more so or not that but like just really
focusing more for sure but just focusing really I
mean I felt like those two were kind of the main
stars if if you will of those characters which
I I found you know I I didn't find that to be
unnecessary or anything which I was fine with it's
well in the tradition yeah for sure but I like
that we were just staying more on on the political
satire and we were just focusing on that and then
obviously we get our Mayhem and our destruction
and this full scale stuff and all our cinematic
shots so you know from that from that standpoint
I I had no issue or problem with what we got from
a character's perspective no totally and there's
so many characters and so many units and they do
a good job for the most part of uh you know is it
would be easy to lose track you know of of all the
different places we go all the different teams and
groups and I thought they managed nicely to you
know not make that too confusing and I I really
like the sort of race between you know building
arms against Godzilla but then also uh you know
taking this theoretical this you know it's such
a great little movie to viice of like here's this
mysterious bit of research left over by this
guy who has a whole relationship to at least
aspects of this scenario and all we've got is
this to work from and then yeah them coming up
with this origami concept like there's so many
things I would love to go back and examine that
was probably one of my favorite sequences when
they are like they they're folding the paper and
they're solving the riddle like that was you one
of the more unique perspectives I thought of the
film as well yeah yeah and I mean I like that this
has that element of sat and I think certainly if
you are Japanese and you live in Japan you will
probably note a lot more nuances of what this
is saying about you know the political system the
the you know Reliance on protocols and certain uh
honorifics and traditional I love that that bit
it's a very American thing so it works I think
on a dual level where she's like can we drop the
honorifics I'm not good at that and like you know
and uh and yeah it's one of those things where
you're like well truly it's not that important
you know like right now in this crisis mode like
it's not what we should be focusing and spending
time on and I thought the movie overall did a nice
job with the satire because they they they put you
in both pairs of shoes I think you're sitting
there going oh guys you know these 20 phone
calls to get to this conclusion is not really
working but also uh it doesn't go so broad as
to be like like ah look at these [__] and it
does make you feel for just the sheer scope of
the situation and the sheer yeah unprecedented
struggle of figuring out any plausible direction
to head in and I thought the film you know did
it good to its credit did a really good job of
giving me a little sympathized Zilla too there in
the end I mean as a force of nature yeah yeah for
sure like I mean it's just doing what it was built
to do you know kind of thing wasn't trying to you
know do destruction on uh you know Mar like not
for the sake of blood lust of course of course it
was just doing what it was born to do I you know
from all the nuclear waste that was left on the
ocean floor that was born out of and uh you know
from that perspective I I did feel bad for him uh
obviously you still got to stop you can't just let
him roam around and do his thing but uh yeah no I
mean from that perspective I I did definitely feel
some sympathy I'm like you got to stop but I still
do feel bad you know type of thing so well it's
nice cuz yeah it's like Godzilla this force of
nature the origins have been updated slightly to
be a bit more I guess ecologically minded in that
it's like nuclear waste was dumped here and some
ancient creature soaked it up this is men caused
this yeah so there is still you know the looming
you know origin of the franchise itself again with
you know the you know the nuclear drop but you
know it's updated here to something that makes a
bit more sense for then the Lord that they apply
with like oh it kind of can if evolve back and
forth depending on you know which setting it needs
to be and whether it's underwater or whether it's
on land and you know oh it it it evolved in this
one way and now needed to regress in order to cool
itself down just some interesting flourishes of
the the science and L like the science fiction of
Godzilla here and so getting I thought I mean the
effects on the creature were really well handled
because they're not always the most photorealistic
you've ever seen however I think the combination
of the editing the cinematography which is which
I think is really great throughout and is great
at ramping up and easing off the gas um and even
the choices of music all that stuff like all the
the film styles are great and and yeah the action
and the monster Kaiju stuff is really striking
fantastic because yeah when you're early on and
you've got that that you know earlier stage or
or you know that regressed cool down phase he's
in like it is so strange and it's almost like
some kind of internet meme you're watching that
some guy who just has really good effect skills
mocked up where it's got these big disconcerting
eyes and it looks more like a lizard you know it
did take me a at first myself I was like ah okay
this is the look we're going for then I but then I
uh grew a likeness to it and then the evolved look
I was like okay this is more traditional Godzilla
but and that's monstrous and Eerie just like when
it's like barfing blood from its gills and stuff
like that and then yeah that was terrifying and
then as it takes further form you know it starts
to resemble in a much more nasty just kind of like
someone scribbled the concept art you know in a
fit of anger just like this sharp molten looking
thing and yeah it does a really I think nice job
of portraying it as this this this force of nature
that is not concerned morally one way or the other
with what's going on on the mainland but also
yeah by the time they're nuking it and and you
know pumping it full of coagulants you do start to
feel for it and and I think that kind of enhances
the idea of what this Godzilla is doing which is
yeah it's not as much about one specifically aim
towards one particular traumatic moment in history
that's in there but now this is more of a you know
shapeshifting and ever sort of uh uh uh what
am I trying to say it's like an Ever evolving
threat that we now have it's like we created this
or we unlocked this Chain Reaction now we have to
coexist with it and I think that nicely keeps in
line with the logical stuff as well as the aspects
that are commenting on you know human society and
how we respond to disasters and how we prioritize
who get saved how we you know attack all that
stuff yeah I have no doubt the writers of this
film saw Teenage Ninja Turtles Secret of the use
and then they saw how the turtles stopped Tokar
and razar they put the fire extinguishers in them
and froze them and then that that's how they came
up with the just one big om yeah exactly exactly
there's my reference for the the video yeah buddy
well all right any stray thoughts before we hit
no just uh I this is really I believe my first
introduction to uh you know God Japanese Godzilla
film so I really enjoyed it it was great again I
loved all the political satire stuff was fantastic
uh I loved the evolving of Godzilla great stuff
and then again the the science based stuff and I
love how you know just physically trying to harm
it without doing the science stuff like just was
love Taps to it I thought that was really unique
and great too so just a lot of great stuff that I
enjoyed and the cinematography is so unique like
the POV shots going inside the computer the pan
out shots so many different elements of this film
that I I really enjoyed absolutely man me too I'm
glad we finally saw this this is definitely like
one of the most striking and and gripping Godzilla
movies I've ever seen and it's really cool after
seeing so much of the monsterverse stuff recently
to come back to to just to see how you know The
Originators of this prolific character franchise
Etc you know redefine it for a new age and I think
that's something about Godzilla that will always
endure is like every generation you can kind of
update it into something quintessential but fresh
and and new and and fully in in utilizing all of
the latest you know approaches to film um so
yeah I thought this was really terrific what
did you guys think leave us your thoughts down
below and uh Hey last but not least let's do a
little patron of the day shout out Andrew Let's
uh what's a good scenario that we can put Adelia
Chamberlain and michale Linden in it's Godzilla
related uh uh scenario what do you think what
do you think a good scenario yeah they're like
trying to fight Godzilla and and uh here hold
on a second nothing's working right now a few
moments later all right Andrew let's do uh let's
do male Linden and adilia Chamberlain and I've
taken the liberty of writing up a little prompt
you know how we do nowadays Chad GPT I have a
YouTube channel absolutely that's what we get
paid the big bucks for to to to type a prompt
uh so I want to give a shout out to two of our
loyal patrons AKA super sexy rejects their names
are Mel Lindon and Adelia Chamberlain and we love
them male is from Sweden he loves James Bond and
Adelia is a movie trivia genius and a very caring
human being depict a short scene only dialogue of
them trying to take down Godzilla using only triv
are you ready Andrew I am ready you're going to
be would you want to be M or or adilia I'm down
with either I love movie trivia and I love
James Bond I'm good with either okay um I
will be Adelia then you can be M do your best
sweetish accents oh thank you all right Adelia
remember how Bond outsmarted his giant enemies
we need that kind of wit here yes nodding eyes
sparkling with excitement absolutely let's use the
classic Godzilla versus Mecca Godzilla trick we
need a distraction something big and flashy like
the time Bond used his Aston Martin's gadgets to
escape got it let's set up a series of large MIRS
around Godzilla the reflection might confuse him
he brilliant and remember in Godzilla king of
the monsters how they calmed Godzilla with the
Orca device let's use a similar sound frequency
to disorient him that sounds so annoying even
Godzilla can stunned it what about the Jaws same
song played backwards perfect that's our secret
weapon a mix of bonds cleverness and our movie
trivia knowledge let's do this I love it and and
Chad GPT even took the time to send us a little
addendum saying the scene Blends male's love for
James Bond and adelia's movie trivia expertise in
a playful and imaginative way suitable for your
YouTube channel shout out thank you chat and uh
and yeah I mean I guess I would love both of you
on my Godzilla survival team by by this shout
out it seems like adilia might be a little bit
more she might have the more pertinent knowledge
just to you know I don't know how many gadgets
we're going to have at our disposal but you know
we need a debonaire guy as well who can get the
Intel so I appreciate you both we love you guys
you guys are some of our most long enduring and
supportive patrons and and in all seriousness we
appreciate you very much we love you guys and uh
and yeah in this Thanksgiving season I don't
know exactly when you are going to be seeing
this but in this Thanksgiving season we are
very thankful for you guys and I hope you stick
around for many moons to come be well people and
we'll catch you on the next one much love cheers